how we doing are we uh are we rolling
Megan we are rolling rolling um I I
we've been shooting all day we've been
shooting the show it's been a joy I've
been in my uh you know no spoiler here
but I've been my American flag bandana
all day this is a lot of fun as far as
we've started referring to it I think
you came up with this started referring
to it as his Americas no Charlie
no no yeah he's got his America's on
yeah I just put it in the script because
I thought it was funny to refer
my Americas is it the jacket like you
have like a jean jacket what's the look
um I got some really good sweatshirts
this year so Charlie picked up some new
Americans you should take those home man
I I will notice I get a few like side
glances from people that are like oh
you're one of those guys so we were
talking about this today in the van I
don't appreciate that I feel like
patriotism has been co-opted by one you
know half of the country and it's like
the whole party yeah everyone's in
America but uh I could already hear the
outrageous I'm a patriot I mean I was
telling you the story the other day when
when uh my my son had his friends over
uh to the house and we were going to
watch the USA Netherlands game uh the
World Cup uh USA Netherlands game and
miles my oldest son his two buddies I
won't name them uh we're like yeah we're
gonna go for the Netherlands
and I was like
wait what what do you mean you're going
for the Netherlands they're like yeah we
want to go for the Netherlands I'm like
right but you're you're Americans I mean
you live in the United States like yeah
we just want to go for the Netherlands
found myself getting genuinely pissed
off oh yeah have we talked about this on
the podcast no no no we haven't because
it's a bunch of crap first of all kid I
did it was it was I was getting pissed
off I don't know if it was you're not
from tell me one thing about the
Netherlands put to the Netherlands on a
map we'll see okay so that was the point
I was making yeah exactly right here's a
map by the way he probably pointed right
up Netherlands I would have pointed it
right out they're still there so much
smarter than we are that's what I'm
saying like they're in geography right
now [__] I bet you they would anyway
whatever but yes but that was the thing
that upset me I'm like do you have
that's what I asked them I said you have
some kind of a tie with another one's
like is are you from there you have some
family there any any connection to the
Netherlands at all Netherlands and I can
and they were like no
and I just was [__] pissed man I was
like Mr Hamilton I don't like rooting
for a loser and I think statistically uh
America's not get out of my house
it was so much jockier I'm with you I'm
well yeah right he's joking it was
jockey it was very jockey it was all
very good oh no we're probably
gonna lose say that but you're probably
right that's what's behind it well
listen
listen I'm a GD Patriot okay I am a
patriot and so I took it very personally
and I I was surprised at how personally
I was taking it but I but it made me in
some ways it made me feel good because
it made me feel like wow I really do
care a lot more about this country than
I even maybe realized and I had a moment
wearing my Americans today aside from
other sideways glances I was getting
from extras we were like is he safe
um where all the bandana this is like
it's a strong Choice yeah yeah but I had
a bit of a Rob Justice to speak about
our absentee friend here but like um
I had a moment where I I was looking at
a guy on set and I was like
this guy does not work here now he
looked like a grip he just looked like a
grip he had a big beard he was a big guy
he'd like uh had on like a kind of a
ruddy baseball hat he had an army
backpack he had a couple things hanging
off the army backpack he was looking at
his cell phone and he was just kind of
hanging around like one of the tents
but I was like
two things I noticed I'm like where's
this dude's walkie right because all the
guys on set have a walkie and
wind this [__] working like
everybody around here is working like
like someone's bringing the pipe over
here and pulling into the backpack for
and what's the backpack why why still
this late into the day like sure you
bring it back but you drop it off and
then you're working and it was just kind
of lingering around and lingering around
I was just like I was watching them I
was like he keeps looking at his phone
and then I I I talked to Zandra who's a
um second 80 yeah yeah second 80. and uh
and I said hey do you recognize this guy
here and look there's hundreds of people
on the set right so it could be I think
I could be day playing you could be
working for the day sure
saying no I don't I don't and she's like
where's this walking like where's
where's the bands walking uh
now he never actually looks at us like
noticing this but he starts to kind of
drift his way off the set and then she
asked like one of the teamsters and then
he like walks off and he did anybody
check his backpack
no like well he took his backpack with
him but no that's what I'm saying
whether it belong to someone else oh no
I won't worry if he like took [__] and
put it in the backpack he definitely
drifted on the set was looking to steal
something no yeah but like you also
don't want to like stop some guy who's
in the electric department and be like
hey man do you work here but like yeah
there's also like you get a weird spidey
sense where you're like oh man I got
some Vibes off this guy and I don't know
what he was doing but something about
your Americas also had you fired up did
you go America all over his ass yeah did
you think about going tomorrow I if I
had to I would have uh but I didn't have
to he sensed the America in me
yeah he wanted to go to war with you you
thought you know what I'm not going more
with this this guy spends a lot on
defense
he's too free yeah he's too free baby
foreign
other than security risks you guys
having fun on set I'm like sad that I
haven't really I stopped by set the
other day for like two seconds well
you're you're directing an episode where
you're gonna direct two episodes yeah a
lot of each other really soon but right
now you're really uh picking up the
slack for us on the last two episodes
which we still need writing and you've
been uh with the room and leading
everyone on the charge of how to get
them good and I know they will be good
because you're very good at your job oh
well thank you I appreciate that and if
they're not I'm gonna scream at you yeah
my America's back on get it get it just
have a backpack just like
[Music]
um uh no it's been fun the last two days
actually we we have a script that we're
sending to you guys today so we wrote
the script out in two days and I really
like it that's the the oh well I can't
say yeah well I know which one it is
maybe we should Rob's not here he
doesn't care about spoilers and uh it
was really great and I think that your
favorite part about the script though is
that it's 25 Pages
longer like that yeah we do like that
because it means we can improv we can
yeah fatten it up on the day yeah one
thing I think we did really well this
season was just getting in a pinch of
like okay
time was getting tight and we're like
okay let's we gotta work fast on some of
these what's a funny location and who
are funny characters and just like you
know bringing the mothers back and Uncle
Jack and you know we were working with
Andrew Friedman today allegedly
allegedly uh and he is so fantastic he's
so funny yeah everything look at the guy
everything he says it's like comedy gold
and we're like
it's lovely too what is that we just
trapped because they're not they don't
come back oh they don't come back I want
to bring them back although we really
have like hasn't happened though no it
hasn't happened we know I mean I'm
trying to single I think there's
something about making a comedy too
where uh I've noticed that even like if
you work with someone who has a
reputation
everyone wants to be on their best
behavior because they they don't want to
kill the The Joy but it starts at the
top too it starts at the top like if the
vibe on set because I think there are
some people who can be yes awful when
they're in a situation where their their
heckles are up or their their egos being
threatened in some way and then they can
go on the offensive but when they feel
like they're in a like a happy place
with happy people who are excited to see
what you have to bring to the table open
to what you have to bring to the table
open your ideas in the movie that I just
did um I won't I worked with an actor
who's a very very well respected very
well-known um actor on this film and you
know when he first showed up I could
tell he was like
he was like
kind of [__] am I going to be
dealing with here you know what I mean
but everybody on that set was great you
know uh including myself I tend to be
you know I'm friendly I'm a nice guy you
know you're great um and uh and he just
he I just watched him like over the
course of the first day of shooting with
him just I just watched him melt and
then by the end of it he was like that
this was amazing like he was like we're
best friends and it was great you know
but he but he came in like because you
don't know what you're gonna get like am
I gonna be dealing with a bunch of
[__] is you know is the guy I'm
Gonna Be Acting with a dick yeah people
can have their guards up
um
I was just the most exciting part of the
process of this movie I directed
directed Fool's Paradise coming out soon
coming up May 12th coming on May 12th in
theaters you get to go see
those theaters I may or may not be in
this movie you are most definitely in
the movie and most definitely fantastic
in the movie uh but uh John Bryan who
did the score for love and Eternal
Sunshine Spotless Mind had been doing
the score and we had a full Orchestra
the other day
and it was the one of the most exciting
things I've ever been a part of you know
I was there thinking okay if I'll you
know chime in I didn't I had to do
nothing but sit back and watch this man
do his magic but uh
here a full Orchestra of musicians
scoring a film and then to know you're
in the same room that they recorded
Wizard of Oz at one point John's like I
get up there and hit that gong time
because they that's the same one they
use in Wizard of Oz you want me to do it
I also think I got the timing wrong like
three times it's like it's fine we can
edit it
that's the magic experience but on that
movie I got to work with Ray Liotta who
hasn't sadly passed away and it's so
awesome he would always kind of call me
over the many years that I was I kept
tinkering in post and rewriting and
reshooting things and he'd be like you
know when's it coming out and uh he was
proud of his own performance in the
movie he has a real comedy he doesn't do
you don't see the guy do a lot of
comedies very funny and I I saw a
transition in him from like day one or
two where he's like all right what's the
vibe here a lot of questions not sure
about everyone to just really sinking in
leaning in and just oh you're gonna let
me be a little free have fun yeah and
like I think I think people really
respond to that the greatest lesson I
had on on this movie was that just get
the most talented people I can and then
let them free you know like working with
John and then you and Ray and uh Leslie
Jones who came in and did an edit Tim
roach you know started Leslie Jones who
also cut punched drunk love and like The
Thin Red Line and amazing movies
just sometimes
a big part of the process is just
finding people and staying out of their
way but there's a long way of talking
about my movie which I'm very excited to
talk about to go back to like good and
bad behavior on set I find that
in comedies like in Horrible Bosses
of course we all know uh
there are some people who have gotten in
trouble since that movie's come out and
might have had reputations of of being
difficult on set but like when people
are with comedy people they
they don't often bring that energy but
you've worked on a show and seen some
really bad behavior yeah there's fun and
it's always tough because just for what
Glenn's talking about it's like you ruin
the mood and like comedy can't really
exist in like or it can but it's like
you have to work so much harder for it I
think one of the things that you guys do
you guys move so quick that it doesn't
have time to become like really boring
and stale and like it stays fun and
joyous yeah and it I have more of the
experience on Sunny of like oh no it's
over when when we're done with the scene
right like even directing I'm like oh I
don't get to okay because we're always
cross shooting the way we are right now
there's a camera here there's a camera
there so when I'm talking to you inside
here once it's all in real time by the
way Danny today we were talking about
that because he said you know can you
not look at Heath uh Colin's great
director but the way we were blocking a
scene with Andrew Friedman is that can
you actually not look at Andrew it's
going to be better if your eyeliners and
you know we were saying
are you sure it's not passable because
the chemistry is going to be better if
I'm actually looking at Andrew he's like
no no it's fine it's I I'm like being
picky and the beauty of the show is that
we do that and Danny was like you know
Milos Foreman was always like that he
goes this one is crisscross crisscross
oh and meaning your eye line is supposed
to be not no uh no meaning that there's
always two cameras but yeah to do that
you sometimes sacrifice the eye line
because you do sacrifice the other
camera yeah yeah you can't get you can't
get your eyes as close to the lens
because you've got another camera
pointed you know where you've got a
camera right next or you know near you
yeah and look in a perfect world you
always have you have time to do all
sorts of different things you you yeah
you do your crisscross and then you can
get within the two actors but well you
just you have to decide on what the
priority of of that particular show is
with the vibe of that particular show is
but I think that's one of the really fun
things about the show is that often
there are multiple characters on camera
at the same time so you can watch an
episode multiple times and never know
have noticed like that person's
reactions while the other person was
talking you know yeah all my favorite
movies are that way are the ones that I
can go back to over and over again and
pull something out of pull something new
out of it yeah yeah well uh speaking of
episodes we we're not talking about ones
yeah well I don't like to talk about
recap any of the ones when you guys
aren't all here yeah so we can't talk
about an episode today because Rob is
somewhere but that's okay that's okay I
thought I you know we're coming at this
little half cocked totally unprepared
totally prepared they're gonna stop on
the Fly we are but and podcasts aren't
that way usually right they're pretty
yeah they're really tightly scripted
yeah
um but I thought it would be really fun
uh since Rob's not here
um to get into a conversation about
acting
oh that's a dig it's not even a fail dig
I'll tell you what though Rob uh
yesterday on set had me in stitches and
I know he doesn't sometimes think of
himself as actor first you know I I if
you put it in order or whatever but man
like
when he Taps into something but when you
have something specific he's playing
something very specific right now he's
doing a very specific gag on the show
that was that you know in in much the
same way that he was doing when he
gained all that weight because you know
to be clear just for one episode it's
like one episode where something is
happening to his character which
physically in the way he sounds and uh I
remember having a lot of fun like
breaking that because I was like you
know this this is probably excited
because it gives them something to do I
know I'd be excited if it was my
storyline in the episode it's always fun
to be like Oh I'm gonna get to yeah just
do something different that I'm normally
doing I went to them nailing it yeah I
went to the makeup trailer to pitch him
the re-break of the story that we were
writing this week and he was getting the
prosthesis on so that was fun like I saw
it happening as I was trying to pitch
augmentation and it was really but you
could tell he was like delighted he was
like look look you know he was like yeah
a kid in a candy store it was good yeah
he really clicks into something when you
give him something uh especially when
you give him something very specific to
play you know and especially when it's
different than what he's used to playing
I mean I think we're all the same way
but we could we could do a in-depth uh
acting our approach to acting uh I just
thought it'd be a good opportunity uh
and you know this might get a little
actor nerdy possibly okay so you know
um but you know just to kind of almost
interview each other
and the the key would be take your own
insecurities out right you hate to like
talk about your process of acting oh no
I love to talk about but
but
um that's that's not a good way to
approach your life for your work you
should yeah you gotta be serious about
your craft i'm interested because I'm a
non-actor so you can explain to me how
acting works yeah well and then at some
point I'd love for you to explain to me
how writing Works uh because I do it but
I still don't get it yeah does anyone
know I don't really have that no no one
knows but nobody knows that what how to
act no one knows how yeah yeah it's just
you know writing I can only do if I'm
like hammering carbs the entire time
apparently because that's what I've been
doing in the writer's room all week okay
stay I'm standing up the whole time and
pacing but also just like hammering
pretzels for some reason right I think
it's just like you need a little treat
while you're working like you need a
little something rain needs fuel your
brain needs food you're draining your
brain yeah yeah you need that extra you
know extra get up and go but when you're
acting carbs are your enemy
yeah you guys yep that's right the
Hollywood rule number 101 well so so I
would start by just asking you okay
you're gonna hit me first
um what was the first what was the very
first
acting thing that you do want to say and
I don't mean like professional I mean
like what was the first time you
performed
maybe you didn't even realize that that
you were acting I was doing plays as the
child like in how young
um well I think the first like
play play was third grade you know I
think uh really yeah I think in in first
grade or kindergarten I I did a thing
where I like walked on and held like the
intermission sign and I remember holding
it upside down and everyone being like
oh that's so cute he got it backwards
but little me was like oh no I knew that
was gonna be funny I did that on purpose
and it was I remember being like scared
that I did it on purpose but like oh man
they don't know that I did this on
purpose like yeah so I'm already trying
to get laughs like from day one that was
your only role and that play was holding
yeah come out to be like intermission
and you figured out how to make it about
you because my mom was
I figured out how to steal the scene
from others uh but like I my you know my
mom's the kindergarten through eighth
grade music teacher so they did like
school plays at the school yeah and
usually players had music and so
um
but
uh oh no it was second grade that we did
um
we did uh James and the Giant Peach okay
so the first the first time you
performed in something it was a it was
an actual play I played James buddy I
had the lead whoa right out the gate
right out the gate well you know what
I'm my teacher
saw something in me first she saw that I
was gonna have to do second grade twice
that was her first observation she's
like that first of all this this kid's
way too young and uh falling behind I
repeat performance of second grade yeah
yeah but then she's like secondly she's
like he's such a clown like why not like
try were you a clown were you kind of
class clownish I think yeah I think
probably you were always making your
friends laugh and we're trying to at
least energetic and probably looking for
attention and but
um
yeah we did James and the Giant Peach
and I had to sing smile though your
heart is breaking and I remember like
having to like work on the song which
was new like having to work on a song
um but I remember being like Oh yeah
this is right and she was like you
should send him to like
uh auditions and and things like that
but my parents thankfully were like no
no he's just gonna be a kid
oh you're you're happy about that though
you didn't didn't want to go the child
star route no I yeah I wasn't really
thinking about it as a career you know I
was like huh that's just the thing I did
um yeah and you were I think you and I
were maybe similar in that way like
because you were doing other things too
you were into sports and yeah I did I
did a play again in fourth grade and
then I didn't do anything until my
senior year of high school uh what wait
a minute so from fourth grade to senior
year of high school you didn't do no
perform at all no no
um Sports and stuff yeah I started
getting more into sports with my uh
baseball right yeah my good buddies in
Rhode Island
um and um super into baseball that was
the main thing and then
wanting to do a play I remember in high
school like seeing the plays in high
school and being like Oh that looks like
so much fun but
not knowing how to juggle that and not
having the confidence to just go sign up
right just being like I don't know I
don't know those kids in that world and
then my scene but you know by the time
you're a senior in high school you you
feel much more confident about yourself
and right at school and so I did it then
um but then yeah then it was I went to
high college and uh was still very into
baseball and then very quickly realized
like oh my baseball career is over and
uh was took like theater one and theater
two which was all my college offer but
they had like an acting Club
and very quickly fell into it being like
oh this is the right fit for me and it
always was and I should have realized
that art the timing was great I'm glad I
didn't do much before
um yeah and then someone while I was
there was like uh hey go check out the
Williamstown theater Festival which is
like a summer theater Festival it's
pretty prestigious thing in Western
Massachusetts and you can intern there
and if you do well you can rise to the
ranks and that just I went that I went
to Summer of my junior year and never
looked back never stopped doing actors
yeah all your friends there too right
yeah all the friends you know here yeah
for you know half the people we know on
the show no Glenn I'm gonna throw it
right back at you where did it all begin
uh for me uh
honestly I think it was
sort of a natural progression from like
I don't know that I was I mean I was I
think I was a little bit class clownish
a little bit but um definitely I was
always a little weird like in the sense
that I would like I was always doing
like voices and you know what I mean
like just being yeah kind of silly and
goofy yeah definitely trying to make my
friends laugh I was always like playing
characters at home you know when I would
watch a movie I would play I would just
start doing the character you know it's
like I didn't know what I was doing I
thought for all I knew every kid did
that you know what I mean it made sense
to me
um and then they're like so nervous
they're like what is he doing what is
this weirdo doing you know it's to
inhabit other bodies
you could be a psycho might be an actor
Glenn just watch don't act along what
just watch not possible no but I see
that right so you're
you're having those feelings that are
like I want to be I just wanted to do it
you know what I mean like I'm performing
in some ways yeah yeah I love watching
movies but I wanted to do it and and I
but I didn't know you know that that was
a thing or that that was an Avenue I
wanted to go down or anything but my
parent my parents actually had the
opposite reaction they they they watched
it and they were like did this guy want
he like wants to do this you know what I
mean like clearly and then by the time I
got to like I think it was fifth grade
and I started doing like and it hadn't
done a play or anything like that but I
was doing sketches like comedy sketches
at school like whenever there was an
opportunity to do something or do
something like that and then my parents
uh there was it in my hometown in
Montgomery Alabama uh the Alabama
Shakespeare Festival
is this great really really awesome
regional theater like right smack dab in
the middle of Montgomery Alabama
and we would see plays there all the
time I grew up watching theater too like
my dad even though he was in the Air
Force and his dad was in the Air Force I
think I've mentioned this before but his
dad was a a jazz musician he played
trumpet he played piano and his mom and
my dad's mom was a dancer so he grew up
around the like very similar to the way
I grew up like both super academic but
also like in the Arts the Arts were
appreciated yeah yeah so we would go see
theater all the time right and so anyway
there was an actor from the Alabama
Shakespeare Festival who was teaching an
acting class for kids and my parents
were like do you want to go do that and
I was like yeah definitely so I was
taking this acting class and then from
there the guy was like hey they need a
kid just like you to play a kid in one
of the plays at the Alabama Shakespeare
Festival would you be interested in
doing that and I was like yes absolutely
you know I mean I'd grown up watching
Shakespeare watching classical theater
watching
you know we lived in England for a short
time and we would go to Stratford upon
Avon and watch the you know Royal
Shakespeare company do their thing and I
just was enthralled by it I thought it
was amazing and so the very first play I
did was uh a play called a month in the
country by Ivan turgeniev so it's like a
Russian you know very chekovian kind of
uh
thing and uh and then that was it I like
I was hooked wait you say um you got
hooked like what was it was it like the
crowd feedback was it just the
experience of doing the acting like what
was the thing that was like oh I could
do this for the rest of my life it was
yeah even then I wasn't thinking of it
uh I wasn't thinking I was going to make
a profession out of it I just
loved it I loved every aspect of it I
love the community I love the people I
love the world I just I loved being on
stage I felt so comfortable on stage
there's a thing too why I'm sure you
probably felt this way where making a
career out of it is doesn't even cross
your mind because no you don't know
anyone who's a professional actor you're
not growing up in Hollywood where you
know so and so's Uncle does it like or
dad it just it's like a foreign world
they're not real people on the screen
you know they're not real people so you
know it just seems
it doesn't even cross your mind
wasn't until yeah it wasn't until
Williamstown that I saw professional
actors who weren't famous that I thought
oh right you don't have to grow up to be
yeah right Tom Cruise you could you know
you can be this guy this person's in his
mid-60s and has been working forever and
I I don't know like I've never heard of
him but he has a career so that's all I
ever wanted you know like
and I didn't really figure it out until
and I kept doing plays all through
Junior High School at my school and high
school
and then but I still didn't know I
wanted to be an actor because I was
doing the same thing as you I was
playing basketball I was playing
football
I was super into weirdly super into Math
and Science and I was going to go to
um to Auburn University to be an
aeronautical engineer I was signed up
for classes
I had a place to live with my friends I
was going to Auburn to be an
aeronautical engineer and then I got a
scholarship
to this school in Miami yo what's that
school called New World School of the
Arts right and you were there for two
years
I was there for two years they they they
had offered me a full scholarship and I
distinctly remember my mom coming to me
and saying and this is such a a rare
thing to happen but it was actually my
mom who came to me and said hey
do you think that if you don't go and
try to be an actor that you're gonna
regret it one day wow that's a weighty
question for yeah because because she
was like because if there's any part of
you that thinks you want to do this you
should do it because it's a full
scholarship it's not going to cost us a
lot of money and if you want to if you
want to quit after a couple years and go
be an aeronautical engineer you can do
that later
you know all right so and I was like
done right so they were there you're in
in college for acting and the bugs [__]
you full-on bite
when does Juilliard start to get on your
radar that it's an option that you want
to audition for it uh and in addition to
that did you audition for all the other
big schools did you audition for Yale
and NYU and Carnegie Mellon or yeah for
a bunch of them
um I I didn't uh audition for those
schools out of high school so I just
took the scholarship went to New World
and then but my roommate uh Chris Romero
shout out
uh
uh Chris Romero's good buddy he was from
New York and his good friend they had
gone to a performing arts high school
together and his good friend his best
friend in New York was going to
Juilliard so he was like after our
second year he's like I think I'm gonna
go audition for for Juilliard and I was
like yeah let's do it and so I went with
him how nervous were you for the for the
auditions
honestly man like not that nervous
really I had such a a degree of
confidence in myself that
was based on I don't know what
I just I just that's great though I
thought I thought at the time I remember
I actually remember sitting in the room
in one of the rooms it's like filled
with actors filled with people and I
remember sitting there and thinking like
these people
is it like a vein thing it was like a
confidence thing talking about like you
I was like I can I I just felt like it
is a profession of deluding yourself oh
totally right like you have to
you don't necessarily have to say I'm
the best at everything but at that young
age it's very useful to walk into an
audition room and be like nah I'm the
best it's a really useful tool just
because then you walk into that room of
that confidence and then on when you
sort of a career you have to develop the
skill of believing you're another person
for you know at least the few seconds
between action and cut if it's on film
but all right so uh you you you do the
audition
you're feeling confident you feel like
it goes well
what how long between the audition and
when you hear you got in and and did you
hear from all the schools did you get
into the mall did you only get into
Juilliard what what happened there yeah
I got into a few I don't remember which
ones but I auditioned in the morning and
then I had to wait a couple hours to
find out who they who was going to get
called back and they only called back
like five people out of like 500 that
were there that day and they auditioned
people all over the all over the country
or whatever so there's only five people
and I got called back so I was like okay
and that was a huge and when that
happened and I was like I got this I
just knew it and now
I could just as easily have not gotten
it but for some reason in my mind I was
like I got this because what that was is
that was like okay I did something right
so then so then for the Callback I kind
of had now is the Callback was in front
of the entire faculty so like before it
was in front of like you know maybe
three or four faculty members
they called me back then it was the
entire faculty like all of the faculty
of Juilliard like
theoretically very intimidating but in
my mind I was like I don't know I I just
I was like okay if I got called back
that means they liked what I did so it
gave me even more confidence to lean
even further into what I felt like
I was capable of so I had even more
confidence I I was even less nervous in
the Callback I mean I was nervous don't
get me wrong I was definitely nervous
but like I don't know I was like I was
capable of like delivering on this thing
I did the same model like is it a
monologue that you deliver for that for
the yeah I had to do yeah we had to do a
classical monologue and a contemporary
monologue and then
and then uh in the Callback I did both
the monologues and then they asked me to
do like some improv stuff and like and
did you do comedy stuff or drama I did
one one was like the classical piece was
like a uh from genre scenes fedra and it
was not comedy like very very serious
and then the and then the Contemporary
was comedic yeah if I had an edge over
other actors I do remember thinking at
the time like because I would watch
other actors do their monologues I'd
seen what they do and I was like
the one thing that's missing from from
almost all these people that I noticed
right away was like they've forgotten
that this is supposed to be fun and
entertaining you know they're forgetting
to entertain it's like it's it's not
about squeezing tears out of your eyes
and making people think like oh wow he's
such an amazing actor it's like [__]
entertain people you know what I mean if
you look like you're having fun up there
everybody kind of relaxes and goes ah
this is this is fun
[Music]
then they want to watch you because you
make them feel good I remember it's not
about you it's about them similar
experience This was later after I was
starting to work at Williamstown a lot
but like we would every now and then do
like Showcase in New York and yeah yeah
yeah I remember like yeah
people do like six really serious
monologues and I come out there and do
something funny that like Eric bozian
wrote and then it's like oh that just
gets everyone's attention yep that's
exactly what I did uh upon graduating
from Juilliard I did we had to do two
you know I did do like a showcase or
whatever we did two two things and I
chose comedies for both because I was
like every single person in my class is
doing these like Ultra serious like deep
heavy and I was like I'm gonna [__]
entertain the [__] out of people yeah
and he's like why not see what happens
yeah
[Music]
Rob's not here so for the purposes of
this ad Charlie will be playing Rob
today we are brought to you by
DraftKings sports book an official
sports betting partner of Super Bowl 57
and guess what new customers can bet
just five dollars and get 200 in free
bets instantly Rob how do you feel about
that
I'll tell you Charlie plus all customers
can get in on the Super Bowl 57
excitement with DraftKings happy hour
super boosts check the DraftKings sports
book app each day between 6 and 9 pm
Eastern to see which prop bet gets
boosted who you got man who who's your
who's your pick this year what do you
mean I got the birds the birds are in it
who do you got my money's on Brady oh
you're not taking the Eagles clip oh I
don't bet against Brady I've learned
that lesson time and time again
I'm Gonna Leave in all this stuff in the
middle
okay one remember when the Eagles beat
him and two Brady's not even playing
what happened is he hurt ah no he just
didn't make it yeah I'm not buying a
nice try though go ahead and bet on him
Glenn leave that Eagles money to the
rest of us download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app and use code always sorry
angry so angry he's just looking for a
bit of Justice probably Glenn yeah so
new customers can bet five dollars on
Super Bowl 57 and get 200 in free bets
instantly only a draftking sports book
with code always now hang on a second
here because minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply void in Ohio
see show notes for details
[Music]
not here today so for
part of Rob
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
turn your hat around backwards baby
an online therapy service where licensed
professionals can help you tackle issues
you may be dealing with or just help you
feel your best in general when do you
guys feel your best me oh uh right after
a shower yeah that's a good one a nice
cold shower oh okay we had me going
there for the first part the second half
kind of threw me dude no cold showers
rule man they're actually proven to
reduce depression and symptoms of
anxiety yeah so you ought to feel your
best you know coming out of one kind of
like a like a great therapy session now
Meg uh you you've used better help right
is it anything like a cold shower yeah I
can attest the better help was great for
me in the sense of working through an
issue with someone I felt like
understood it I can't attest to the
whole cold shower thing but right it's
pretty good right right you guys are
missing out on greatness better help as
stimulating as a Polar Plunge in a good
way if I'm being unclear and it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online
this is if you want to live a more
empowered life
therapy can get you there so visit
betterhealth.com sunny today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny thanks Rob
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I went one summer as an intern to
Williamstown and then you can audition
to get in I remember
being so nervous about the audition
and I'm just like I went across the
street to get a beer to like calm down
and like I was like 21 I think um maybe
22 already but like I'm in the audition
and I'm doing
Danny in a deep blue sea I think it was
yeah and uh
I'm saying my line and he's like this
kind of like brooding guy it's like uh
before I only did comedy [__] like
I played like a blue collar kind of
brooding guy and I I kind of like
punched the air conditioner like not
hard but just like a little like you
know like whatever the line is the thing
like
front of it comes off the wall and
crashes
and I just quickly improv like see
everything I touched turns to [__] and
then I just keep going on nice
apparently someone pulled me aside after
I'd gone in and be like that's what
for us all of a sudden like oh he's yeah
he's an act because he's in it like he's
in it yeah yeah he wasn't thrown by that
he wasn't thrown by it right which is
you never know like what little moment
well I learned very quickly I'm like
that lesson of like oh people only get
uncomfortable if you're uncomfortable
sure you know what I mean so if you [__]
up
you know like and I I well that's a bit
like like when you watch people host SNL
if they seem like they're having fun
yeah it's a great episode yeah if they
seem like they're nervous up there oh
but you get nervous yeah the audience is
like feels bad for them and so I I
always notice it's like the audience
doesn't want to make any noise almost
because they they're they're too worried
to make noise one way or the other I
feel like the person then it gets but
yeah when you come out and you're like I
got this like don't worry I take yeah
you exude that but I don't know that you
can fake that I think like you really
have to be feeling like I tried to do
stand-up for a while when I first
started comedy in New York and like I
just wasn't enjoying myself on stage so
I could write funny jokes but like you
could just tell when I was up there that
I wasn't liking it and so then the
audience like didn't like yeah I feel as
though you've gotten more comfortable
with the concept of being a performer
just from doing this podcast no yeah
that's a good question I I was I thought
about that too I'm like I'm like are you
weird becoming like more comfortable on
camera and more at ease performing no
it's still really hard for me to watch
the edits of these and I and I like I'm
irritated I I don't I don't enjoy
watching it but I don't think of this as
a performance I think of this as just
talking to you guys which I enjoy doing
and which I've gotten comfortable doing
because we're in the room so to the
extent that I perform in front of you
because I pitch you guys stuff and like
try to entertain you and make you laugh
I feel comfortable doing that but I
don't really just like in my mind think
of this going out anywhere I know that
it does yeah yeah
uncomfortable with like seeing yourself
on camera you're the same as every
performer in the history of show
business but it's amazing you guys can
watch yourselves perform as much as you
do because you're in the edit Bay
watching it all the time and not have
that like wait I'll tell you what it's a
good way of just like uh just getting
over it yeah because like you just do it
for so many years you're like I guess
that's what I look and sound like you
know like I thought I was completely
over it after spending years and years
in the edit uh on the show and then I
watched you know a cut of uh the
I think I can yeah the Blackberry movie
I was like can I talk about this yet
yeah and I was like oh and I and I
thought the movie was great but I just I
was like God this is really hard to
watch myself oh really yeah and I just I
know the way you looked
no no not the way I looked no um my
acting oh well
in in this role I will say I mean I I am
uh exploiting a side of myself that I
don't like
that's there that I repress because it's
not because it's ugly and I don't like
it I don't like it as a as I don't like
people that are like that
and it
the role requires me to required me to
uh be a person that I don't like and so
when I watch it I'm like I don't like
that person oh okay well that's
different than not liking your acting I
think you like her acting so much yeah
no I know all right so you you go
through uh Juilliard you get an agent
from a Juilliard showcase and then
you're pretty much off the races I did
exactly what they told us not to do and
they were like don't sign with somebody
until you do the showcases but by the
time we do the showcases well we had
this conversation the other day and the
van to set where somehow we were talking
about that time of our lives and I was
saying you know I I had around that time
I thought oh boy it'd be nice to go to
an acting conservatory and get that
training but I I also had through
Williamstown got an agent was starting
to get auditions we're starting to get
roles so I was like well that feels like
a step backwards totally and I also was
like I have a lot of
confidence and I don't want to spend
four years having someone break me down
and be like hey your voice is too high
and Scratchy you know or like whatever
it is so I was like ah [__] it that's a
good Instinct but yeah I think I dodged
a bullet there but me too and I was
saying you know was it tough to survive
that and you said a really funny thing
about and I think it's the absolute
right advice which is that you learn to
just ignore the acting advice which is
to say I might think you're right but
you say you're not not listening you're
listening to what they have to say and
if something you like from it you'll use
it otherwise you'll ignore it you know
it's funny the part of that story that I
didn't tell was that in my Rebellion
against what I was being taught
I I learned that I hadn't really been
listening before and I started actually
listening because I gave I gave up on
trying to I think when you go to such a
prestigious institution like
Juilliard because it's got this like
stigma attached to it albeit a positive
one I guess but um is you you you just
you have so much deference for the
teachers there right and and I saw I I
realized at a certain point in my
this was actually the beginning of my
third year there that I got some really
bad feedback in a play and it pissed me
off so bad
that I just went [__] this [__] I'm not
going to listen to anything else these
people say yeah [__] it I'm just gonna
I'm I was like I was like I've forgotten
what it was like to enjoy acting I'm
gonna go back to that I'm not gonna do
anything they tell me to do I'm just
gonna have fun
and in that what I learned was I was
like oh I've been doing
and so much many of us have been doing
the program in order to please the
teachers right in order to make them be
like you're getting it yes yes yes you
know
and then I and I realized I was like I
was like why am I doing this for them
I'm the one who's spending all the money
to go here this is for me I'm like
they're there to serve me to serve as
fast you know for your age because yeah
you're young You're vulnerable you want
like that's around the age where you
said okay I'm committing to acting so
you want it bad right like and
I was so lucky because my parents were
so loving and supportive
that I felt like I had a foundation of
love and support so it was like in some
ways the love and support of the
teachers was became less important to me
because I was like I I have that I don't
need that [__] I need you to teach me
how to act and if you don't like what
I'm doing I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] yeah you're not the [__]
audience you're not the [__] audience
you're my teacher teach me how to act if
you don't like something let's fix it
let's work on it that's fine but don't
try and [__] berate me don't bring me
don't try to tear me down
there's not a science and there's no one
way that's going to work for everyone
like yeah everyone has a different
method of how they get to do it and then
everyone has different opinions on
whether or not they're doing it well
like you can teach someone how to fly a
plane and you go you better be pretty
damn exact about that yeah yeah but you
know like
yeah you don't want to get two Arts
artsy fartsy about flying an airplane
right yeah
[Laughter]
not killing everyone on the planet yeah
yeah
[Music]
advice I got I also got a lot of bad
advice and still to this day get bad
advice I mean even on this movie that
I'm finally getting out there like you
know when I was
we're trying to retool it and re-edit it
and work on scripts I sent it to one
writer friend who's like you've got a
great acting career just give up move on
I'm like give up
I love this thing
I'm talking about making changes yeah
yeah so you know if you have a passion
and a vision you have to and like if you
want to be an actor or a writer and you
are passion you have Vision you have to
like
go all all
coins in oh boy oh God's blazing there's
really no like good ideas that aren't
ideas that someone saw through to the
end of being like nothing just is so
good that it kind of moves itself like a
person pushed that Boulder almost every
single time somebody had a push really
and and you only and getting to the end
realized that it was a good idea at the
end of it but like it's it's it's not
that I I've had this with scripts like
the scripts that end up really great and
the scripts ended up horrible were
equally as hard to make you know you
just have to keep pushing through to the
end to see whether it's going to like
work or not we've all known those people
too who are just like
who were just like how do I become a
professional writer and you're like well
first of all if you what have you
written oh well nothing oh well then
you're [__] yeah and you know right
away you're like you're never gonna you
are never gonna work try it out see if
you like you're never gonna work same
thing with like I would have actors like
actor friends
you know come to me and be like how do I
get an agent and I'm like well are you
doing anything right now no like well
why aren't you doing a play oh yeah I
don't know I'm like are you in an acting
class no I'm like you're not so you're
not doing anything you're not like just
waiting for somebody to give you a job
instead of building your skills that can
get you that job yes and once you get
the job you know how to do the job you
know how to do the job because you've
been practicing I was listening to
interview with uh Scorsese and DeNiro I
was just like flipping through what like
podcasts I've been dealing with a lot of
traffic working on this a lot so I was
like all right I was like oh wow this is
an old interview of these guys from
Tribeca Film Festival talking about
their movies and it was so interesting
to hear how many of the movies they did
De Niro was bringing to Scorsese being
like we should do this one we should do
text we should do um uh I think it was
Raging Bull we should we should do
casino and you're like
right he's not just waiting he's like
come on man I want and these are some of
his most iconic film roles yeah if you
really want to get the things that
you're passionate about that you're
actually excited about not just work you
know uh you have to yeah you got to
continue to hustle
the phone is ringing for so very few
people and what's interesting is like
you get to a certain point the calls you
get are are the movies where you'll help
them where it's like hey we can't get
the money but you'll help that's right
yeah but you don't get the calls where
the it will help you that's exactly
right that's a really good point unless
you're actually and then every now and
then no you're 100 right yeah or you're
bringing to the table like you wrote the
movie like you wrote the movie yeah so
you get to be the lead of it and then
you get to cast it even then it's like a
constant battle even to get it done and
get it sold and like then you get stuck
because you want it to be great and you
know I I fortunately I got to call
Guillermo and Guillermo was wasn't like
hey give up he was like put everything
into making it as good as you can and he
was a thank God I did Guillermo of
course being most famous for playing
football yeah
yeah well that's how you guys started
doing it why are you still doing it
still doing what acting yeah I
I I I love it so much I have often uh
you know I just I've said so many times
I'm like I just want to be an actor I
just want to be an actor I don't want to
don't want to write I don't want to
produce and and yet I can't seem to stay
away from all the other stuff too I
don't know it's like uh
I can't I think I just can't I don't
have really I'm not good at just sitting
back and waiting for things to happen so
I inevitably end up getting involved in
something and I mean God knows like I've
I've tried to write and produce so many
things that did haven't gotten made sure
I have imposter syndrome when it comes
to almost everything other than just
being an actor uh
I've been writing on Sunny for 16 years
since the very very beginning and
you know when people refer to me as a
writer I'm like nope
I don't know what you're talking about I
don't have no idea how to write
which is ridiculous yeah ridiculous you
know what I mean I I still struggle with
identifying as anything other than an
actor well going back to the uh you know
whether or not someone should or
shouldn't pursue acting
I don't know any by this point in our
lives we know people who started out and
have sort of given it up I don't know a
single person that's that who gave it up
who regrets the time that they did it
sure right like I I don't know anyone
who was like oh man I really regretted
doing those three movies or doing those
plays or doing
that television series whatever it was
so I I think there is value if if it is
something that you really feel as though
you love and you want to do
yeah give him a shot give it a shot